I love standup comedy but unfortunately
my favorite standup comic is no longer
with us so I have to settle for other
Comics who are good in their own right
including Dave Chappelle so I watched
Dave Chappelle's latest special and
coincidentally what do you know it would
open up with a joke inspired by nor
McDonald and what Norm did which I'll
never forget is he knew that I was the
biggest Jim Carrey fan in the world now
I'm not going to go all into it but Jim
Cary is talented in a way that you can't
practice or rehearse what a god-given
talent I was fascinated with him and no
knew that and he called me up and he
goes Dave them he says I'm doing a movie
with Jim Carrey
um do you want to meet him and I said
yes I do and it was the first time I
could remember since my father died
being excited and the movie was called
man on the moon I didn't know any of
this and in this movie Jim Carrey was
playing another comedian I admired the
late great Andy
Kaufman yes and Jim Cary was so immersed
in that role that from the moment he
woke up to the time he went to bed at
night he would live his life as Andy
Kaufman I didn't know that when they
said cut this was
still Andy cauan so much so that
everybody on the crew called him Andy I
didn't know any of that I just went
there to meet him and when he walked
into the room where we were supposed to
meet I screamed Jim Carrey and everyone
said no
call him
Andy and I didn't understand and then he
came over and he was acting weird I
didn't know he was acting like Andy cof
me she's like hey how you doing and I
was like
hello
Andy I was very
disappointed cuz I wanted to meet Jim
carried and I had to Pretend This was
Andy Kaufman all afternoon
he was clearly Jim Carrey I could look
at him and I could see he was Jim
Carrey anyway I say all that to say
that's how trans people make me
feel great bit because it's leaning into
what got Chappelle in trouble last time
which was he made a joke about
transgenderism and then the crazy libes
tried to destroy his life and career but
curiously Netflix even though it's a big
lib Hollywood company does see like
comedy so they stood by him he gets
another special they don't completely
destroy his career and he doubles down
the joke is a norm style joke it's a
long shaggy dog story with a punchline
that doesn't really seem to have
anything to do with what just came
before it kind of like Norm's moth joke
where he tells The Death of Ivan ilich
by Leo Tolstoy and then the punch line
is a moth is attracted to a light bulb
and that that's the same here this is a
whole story but Jim Carrey and Andy C
whatever and the punchline is yeah trans
people aren't real but the punch line is
it's not they're just they're not you
can't be a man you're not really a woman
if you're a man I ain't doing trans
jokes no more you know what I'm going to
do tonight
tonight I'm doing all handicap jokes
well they're not as organized as the
gays and I love punching
down there's probably a handicap in the
back right now cuz that's where they
usually make them
sit I came here to laugh at transgender
people know this was going to make jokes
about us come on y'all let's get the fu
up out of
here yeah it's about time somebody let
these handicaps have
it let them at their match tonight the
guy is so bold I call it bold and bright
what's so bold here is he's not just
making a joke oh no look I'm not I'm not
doing trans anymore ha I'm going to do
handicap jokes now
okay any then he does the handicap joke
this is the the type of joke that would
be most taboo you're talking about
people who truly are victimized who have
been legitimately dealt a very tough
hand no comedian would do it he doesn't
do it in a mean way he's not really
making fun of handicapped people he's
making fun of the controversy about him
making fun of transgenderism so he does
that he goes on he's even he's even
really telling a joke about the very
idea of telling a joke and then he gets
specific
and he tells a joke about a specific guy
former Republican Congressman Madison
cin he was like Washington is worse in
Hollywood I was at home like what he
said these people are disgusting they
have orgies and sex parties and Drug
parties and I was think this sounds like
juicy
smoyer he's lying now I don't doubt that
they do this kind of in Washington but I
doubt he's seen it with his own
eyes because who the invites a
paraplegic to an origy it's a great bit
see Chappelle is really good at this the
thing that he's ostensively making fun
of here is this crazy Madison Cur and
right-winger talking about how there are
sex parties in Washington what a big
dummy that's so ridiculous get out of
here but the esoteric joke is yeah of
course Madison CN was totally right he's
absolutely right by saying yeah no I bet
all of that's true I just don't think
they invite you cuz you're crippled by
by doing that you're totally subverted
where some of the audience might have
thought the joke was going you're
totally undercutting the point it's very
very good right now go to hall.com what
better New Year's resolution than
building a daily habit of prayer and
meditation prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude hallow is the
number one Christian Prayer app in the
United States it has helped many
maintain a daily prayer routine it can
help you too download hall right now at
hall.com
slns you can set prayer reminders and
track your progress along the way are
you not sure where to start we'll check
out father Mike schmitz's Bible in a
year or as I call it Bible in four years
but I keep chugging along and it's an
excellent podcast probably my very
favorite one it's available on the
Hallow app you get brief daily readings
and Reflections you can join Mark
Wahlberg Jim cavel even some worldclass
athletes with hallow you can customize a
personal prayer plan and listen wherever
you are with downloadable offline
sessions you need to have a relationship
with God and you need to be a better
person and you need to be holy and the
only way to do that is to pray so you
need to start praying right now download
hallow at hall.com NSC wle get an
exclusive 3 months free that is 3 months
absolutely free at hall.com
can wle God forbid I ever go to
jail but if I do I hope it's in
California cuz as soon as the judge
sentenc me I'll be like your honor
before you senten me I just want the
court to
know I identify as a
woman send me to woman's
jail and as soon I get in there you know
what I'm going to be doing give me a
fruit cocktail before I knock your
mother teeth out I'm a girl just like
[Music]
you
see it's a great bit the specificity of
fruit cocktail is really funny like what
matters in prison you know you think of
Dave chelle's famous Rich comedian in
there but the fact that he becomes so
aggressive and obscene and brutal is
great because he's leaning into the
biggest caricature of the this is it he
won't back away from it can't stop won't
stop he makes another joke vaguely not
vaguely I guess fairly directly related
to rape and they said I triggered him
because because I had done LBGTQ jokes
and it and it turns out this fell was a
bee that was the headline of the article
that said Dave Chappelle's alleged
attacker is bisexual I said alleged
attacker this mother definitely attacked
me I'll show you the
tape he's allegedly
bisexual I'm going to need to see him
suck somebody's before I believe the
rest of this
article I read that in the paper I was
horrified I like bisexual I could have
been
raped
so he even shows he's going to go even
further it's not just the trans jokes
he's going to go after this whole
LGBT movement and all of the political
correctness around it and he's making a
joke about when he was attacked on stage
at the Hollywood Bowl up until this
point he's been making largely Normie
jokes I don't mean Normie like only
relating to nor McDonald as the first
one was I mean they're totally
mainstream jokes he starts to get a
little weirder in his jok when he tells
a joke about that submersible that
exploded by the Titanic well this next
joke is one of those jokes
that it's not you know what I mean I
like to tell it but it never does good
but I'm going to do it and you know why
it doesn't do good I'm not good at
Impressions but this is an impression
you ready
okay this is my impression of the dead
people on the Titanic as the submersible
was approaching this
ship that's good enough all all right
here it
goes join us in our watery
grave oh that's that's awful the joke is
they all died underwater in the same way
like this one group of people died
underwater and then this other group
went down to see them and they also died
underwater why would you go why'd you go
to this place you know this doesn't seem
like a good spot to go and so he's
merely taking a very dark situation that
could be used for really dark comedy and
he's just saying hey look at that but he
he can say hey look at that in a way
that does make you laugh okay then he
moves on to the final Target of the
night he goes back to LGBT the whole
special could be about LGBT he goes back
to L NS x what about you what do you
want to be when you grow up I don't want
to
say cuz I don't want the other kids to
laugh at
me who cares if they laugh your dream is
yours
own your dreams so they can come true
say it loud and proud what do you want
to be when you grow up little
NX that stood up in front of the whole
class I want to be the gayest that ever
Liv like it's part of this old bit where
it's like what do you want to be a
fireman what do you want to be a this or
that what and what do you want to be and
that's it that's it's very simple but
the reason Chappelle can do that now is
because these are the things you're not
allowed to say Chappelle is obviously a
masterful comedian it's a good special
you should watch it I'll see you next
time